Movies are meant to inspire us, scare us,
make us laugh, and make us cry.
But sometimes they just leave us absolutely,
totally confused.
2017 was a particularly dense year of confounding
movies, so get ready to get confused.
Here are a few films that will bust your brain.
And consider yourself warned: there will be
spoilers.
The Bad Batch
Set in the near future, The Bad Batch is about
a group of criminal exiles who've been left
to live in a lawless, cannibal-riddled wilderness.
The neon-drenched backdrop of Comfort — the
central society where humans eat rabbits and
not each other — serves as a stark contrast
to the mania going on beyond the fence, where
civilization and civility are null and void.
In a grim introduction, Suki Waterhouse's
Arlen is tattooed with a prison number and
dumped in the desert.
Soon after, she's abducted and drugged; and
her limbs are amputated and devoured by a
group of cannibals.
Months later, she stumbles across a mother
and daughter scavenging the landscape, and,
upon realizing they're cannibals, she takes
out the mother and abducts the daughter as
an act of revenge.
The women turn out to be the family of Miami
Man, who sets out to search for them and makes
an unlikely acquaintanceship with Arlen along
the way.
He doesn't know she's responsible for his
daughter's disappearance, of course, so he
asks her to help with the search, and the
pair strike a peculiar friendship.
Jason Momoa's character doesn't bother to
hide his brutality, and Arlen makes it known
that she hates his kind, and somehow it just
works.
But this is where the film's plot starts to
get lazy and go off the rails.
Arlen does help Miami Man find his daughter,
and when they're all finally reunited, somehow,
it's never revealed that Arlen put mommy dearest
in an early grave.
Instead, she rejects a chance to stay in Comfort
and shack up with Keanu Reeves' leader character,
and ventures back into the bitter beyond with
Miami Man, essentially taking the place of
the woman she axed.
By the end, the movie makes so little sense
that its title couldn't possibly be more appropriate.
Personal Shopper
Featuring apparitions, half-open doors, and
things-that-go-bump-in-the-night, Personal
Shopper has all the trimmings of a traditional
supernatural horror.
But Olivier Assayas' thoughtful meditation
on grief is anything but ordinary, swapping
jump scares for ambiguous, psychological trickery.
The film centers on Kristen Stewart's Maureen,
a personal shopper by day and spirit medium
by night.
After her twin brother passes away from a
heart condition, Maureen sets down a paranormal
path of discovery to make good on a deal the
pair had during his lifetime: the first to
go would contact the other from beyond the
grave.
Throughout the film, Assayas crafts a nuanced
story that interweaves the narrative of Maureen's
grief with the gruesome slaying of her celebrity
boss.
This is where the lines between reality, the
paranormal, and her own wild imagination begin
to blur.
Whether Maureen really is communicating with
her late brother or being manipulated due
to her fragile mental state, is far from clear,
leaving a lot of room for interpretation and
puzzlement.
Assayas himself later clarified the meaning
of the movie -- that Maureen was simply grieving
her loss the only way she knew how -- but
anyone who saw this one in the theaters last
year was almost certainly scratching their
heads after the credits rolled.
Colossal
This is a monster movie with a colossal twist.
After repeated drunken misbehaviour, Anne
Hathaway's Gloria is thrown out of her boyfriend's
apartment in New York.
Determined to get her life on track, she returns
to her hometown in New England, where she
bumps into an old friend in Jason Sudeikis'
Oscar, and her drinking problems persist.
At the same time, director Nacho Vigalondo
throws up surprise after surprise, starting
with the casual introduction of a monster
attack in Seoul, South Korea.
That may seem at odds with the film's palette,
but the attack does have a direct link with
Gloria's story — as she's somehow inexplicably
linked to the beast.
When Oscar discovers he also has the same
monster-replicating superpower, Colossal follows
another tonal shift.
Oscar shows his sinister side, callously manipulating
Gloria by threatening to use his own monster
to kill thousands of people if she doesn't
comply with his demands.
Oscar's chilling behavior turns the monster
storyline into a conduit for emotional and
physical abuse and leaves Gloria with the
challenge of overcoming her demons, both real
and imagined.
Vigalondo uses monster-movie tropes to provide
a shrewd commentary on very real issues, and
while it is executed well, it's bound to give
audiences whiplash with so many bizarre swerves.
Song to Song
Terrence Malick's filmmaking style frequently
divides opinion, and Song to Song is no different.
Malick depicts a love-hexagon of the privileged
in a way only he can, weaving a complex web
of infidelity, betrayal, broken hearts, and
sentimentality in fluid edits and unconventional
framing.
The narrative itself is straightforward.
Set in the cutthroat music industry, Rooney
Mara's hopeful musician Faye begins an ill-conceived
relationship with Michael Fassbender's powerful
music producer Cook to help her career.
However, she falls in love with Ryan Gosling's
B.V., another musician working closely with
Cook and begins a relationship with him as
well.
After forming a three-way friendship, Faye,
B.V., and Cook navigate the landscape of music
festivals and cocktail parties, as Faye's
infidelity continues.
What makes Song to Song both brilliant and
baffling is its replication of memory and
consciousness.
The story unfolds as if Malick cherry-picked
individual characters' reflections directly
from their brains and scrambled them together
into a collective stream of consciousness
that warps the linear narrative structure.
Like raw memories themselves, the flow of
the story abruptly diverts, changing direction
on a whim, and by the end of it, it's hard
to figure out what just played out on-screen.
A Cure for Wellness
Set in the breathtaking backdrop of the Swiss
Alps, no one can claim Gore Verbinski's aesthetically
pleasing thriller lacks ambition.
In fact, A Cure for Wellness suffers from
being overly ambitious.
Like its mountainous terrain, the story twists,
turns, and ultimately disorients its audience.
Events initially appear straightforward.
Dane DeHaan's up-and-coming executive Lockhart
is tasked with retrieving his company's CEO
from a hiatus at a Swiss wellness center.
To his frustration, the staff at the center
won't allow him to talk to the guy, and on
his way out of the center, he's involved in
a car crash.
He awakens from the accident to find himself
a patient at the same wellness center, with
his leg broken and covered in plaster.
It's then that Lockhart and his crutches squeak
their way through a hallucinogenic journey
filled with freaky imagery.
The center is hiding a terrible secret, and
Lockhart is on a mission to find out what.
The slow-reveal of the truth is frustrating
and borderline nonsensical, as we discover
the center's doctor has been extending his
own age by siphoning off substances from patients.
"No one ever leaves."
By the time the film serves up its final surprise,
though, the audience's appetite for weirdness
has long been satisfied.
Raw
Julia Ducournau brings a fresh look at eating
human flesh with Raw, the second cannibal-themed
movie on this list.
Unlike The Bad Batch, Raw gets under the skin
because of its eerie authenticity, replacing
a dystopian wasteland with the familiar backdrop
of a university.
This realistic depiction makes the French-Belgian
horror too strong for some; at the 2016 Toronto
Film Festival, there were reports of audience
members fainting.
Such a visceral reaction is understandable.
Raw begins like an innocuous coming-of-age
tale with a young woman leaving home to join
veterinary school, where her sister is also
studying.
During an unforgiving hazing process, she
breaks her strict vegetarianism when she is
forced by her sister to consume a raw rabbit
kidney, and this is where things get weird.
Really weird.
Having had a taste, our heroine then embarks
on a cannibalistic quest for flesh that quickly
grows out of hand.
Ducournau doesn't broach such a taboo subject
gratuitously.
Raw is hard to comprehend, but the conclusion
will leave chills down your spine — and
a bite mark on the memory.
mother!
Director Darren Aronofsky said the script
for mother! poured out of him like a "fever
dream", and the result dives to surprisingly
dark depths of nightmarish vulgarity, ultra-violence
and barbaric bewilderment.
It begins with Jennifer Lawrence's title character
and Javier Bardem's 'Him' living a life of
quiet solitude, when Ed Harris' 'Man' makes
an unsolicited appearance at their door, asking
to stay, followed by his wife, Michelle Pfeiffer's
'Woman'.
Much like the flames that engulf the house
at the beginning and end, events rapidly blaze
out of control as more and more people arrive.
Its entirety takes place within the claustrophobic
and confined setting, which eventually descends
into a war zone, and an all-out assault on
the senses.
On top of graphic violence, mother's most
unnerving moments are delivered with everyday,
social non-conforming malice, where strangers
show complete disregard for her wishes.
Trying to decipher the surreality at face
value left many moviegoers guessing, which
is why Aronofsky had to come out and tell
people he meant this to be a biblical allegory.
Mother represents creation, Him represents
God, and the people are the destroyers of
both.
Considering how batty the movie is, though,
it could mean a whole bunch of other things
or nothing at all, at the same time.
Killing of a Sacred Deer
Yorgos Lanthimos is no stranger to eccentricity.
He directed 2016's The Lobster, a story about
a hotel where its single residents have 45
days to find a new romantic partner or else
they turn into animals.
Initially, The Killing of a Sacred Deer appears
less bizarre.
Scratch a scalpel under the surface though,
and Lanthimos outshines his earlier effort.
The story focuses on Colin Farrell's talented
surgeon Steven who befriends a boy named Martin.
Sprinkled with the director's trademark deadpan
dialogue, there are numerous quirks and dark
humor moments that require close inspection.
There's the weird obsession with body hair,
and Nicole Kidman's character pretending to
be an anesthetized patient just to be kinky.
And that's nothing compared to story's core.
Martin is out for revenge, believing Farrell's
character to be responsible for the demise
of his father.
Martin tells Steven he has placed a curse
on his family in an act of vengeance.
To undo the curse, Steven has to kill a member
of his own family, or they will all die slow
painful deaths.
Much to Steven's exasperation, Martin's curse
begins to manifest as his children lose the
ability to walk.
"My legs, they're numb."
How Martin enacts the curse is anyone's guess;
he's seemingly able to make symptoms come
and go.
Those looking for answers won't get anything
concrete either, and it's compounded by an
ambiguous ending that gives little away.
The Snowman
Expectations were high for this film because
director Tomas Alfredson was the mastermind
behind one of the finest horror films of a
generation, Let the Right One In, and The
Snowman boasted Michael Fassbender in the
lead.
With such talent on both sides of the camera,
how did the film end up with a 7% score on
Rotten Tomatoes?
The issue certainly wasn't Jo Nesbø's source
material.
His novel of the same name is the seventh
featuring alcoholic detective Harry Hole.
Following the same premise as Nesbø's novel,
the story follows Hole as he searches for
a depraved serial slayer whose trademark is
to leave a snowman at his victim's houses.
Unfortunately, issues with production melted
any hopes of The Snowman being a hit.
Alfredson admitted that a tight production
schedule left the film as a "big jigsaw puzzle"
with "a few pieces missing."
The result is a disjointed and confusing experience,
with choppy editing, important storylines
that are never concluded, and characters introduced
and later disappearing with no rhyme or reason.
Making matters worse, the marketing campaign
for the film became an unintentionally hilarious
meme, which is hardly the way to make audiences
take your thriller pic seriously.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!